so my name my name is Bella Hadid Selena
Gomez showing Bella Hadid some love I
love it in a new tick tock cell tries
out a filter inspired by the model
writing I wish I was as pretty as Bella
Hadid I'm very honest though in general
cell also admits Bella's her girl crush
I think it's kind of telling she even
trolls herself with a follow-up video
instead this is me my name Selena Gomez
say it doesn't even sound sexy the
singer's post seemingly put few rumors
between the two to rest fans will
remember both women have dating history
with the weekend and in 2019 they
unfollowed and re-followed each other on
Instagram sparking speculation of beef
I'm constantly somebody that likes to
grow and feel like all right what could
I be better at what could I do better at
while there's apparently no bad blood
blood between them now Selena's
maintained a constant Mission when it
comes to using social media I'm very
lucky that I have the platform I have
but on social media it's as much as it's
a blessing and it's fun it it can really
tear people down and I always hope that
the people I'm involved with or support
me can just kind of spread love within
that you know it's hard yep she's
committed to spreading kindness online
and seems tick tocks the place to do it
I think it's a much more easy flowing
Kinder community on tick tock
foreign
[Music]